hey everyone it's Mike from overflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
we're going to be talking about you know
the bouncing Market how to use the order
flow to
um sort of catch these uh markets when
they're bouncing off of lows instead of
going down and making new lows you know
because today was a great example right
we I mean right now we got this big
massive rally taking place underway but
you know today we had new lows a nice
bounce up right and so it's a you know
from 13 and a quarter all the way up to
24 nice 10 point bounce we came down
here to oh four and three quarters we
bounced all the way back up to 14
another 10 point bounce right even down
here at this low
um 92 and a quarter you know back up to
O2 another 10 point bounce
and you know sometimes there's signs in
the Overflow that can sort of key you in
on bounces like this right and there's
other times where the market just
doesn't bounce like here we got the
small bounce and uh you know
we got this nice I don't call this a
balance this is more of a rally taking
place here where we're literally going
from 77
um you know we're up about uh cash
between 13 and a quarter right now so
you know that that's 30 point move off
of the lows so
that's where the order flow is going to
help you in determining you know which
loads you can buy now I'm not trying to
tell you how to predict a low right but
rather use the information that's coming
in on the order flow at the low to sort
of give you signs that maybe the market
can have a nice balance as opposed to
um just sort of trading a little higher
and then coming off making new lows
going sideways making new lows you know
going sideways making new lows and
Etc so again you know if you enjoy my
videos be sure to hit the Subscribe
button you know I like to uh I'm a stat
guy I do like to follow those stats and
hit the notification Bell so you don't
miss any new video that I upload and if
you find today's video helpful be sure
to leave a comment below so let's go
ahead and talk about today's topic all
right so again you know right now it's
Wednesday the 27th it's about two just
before you know it's about 1 40 in the
afternoon s p Showdown about uh you know
Harley you know I'll say we're down but
you know just kind of actually to
unchanged you know down point zero six
but we were down uh much lower earlier
so on the order flow let's take a look
at some of these lows how they're made
right because this is you know the
information that you see in the order
flow is very helpful at times okay I
mean sometimes you know you wish you'd
get more information out of the order
flow
but you know it's sort of the
misconception that people have is that
order flow is going to give you every
single turning point in the market no
that's not what it's does but
what the order flow does tell you is
those times where things are very clear
as to what's happening in the market
right the markets exist to facilitate
trade between one party to another to
transfer that risk and sometimes it does
leave a very clear footprint in no pun
intended of what the big Traders the
institutional Traders are doing all
right so here today we're coming down
into these lows here at 43 13 and a
quarter
all right and we're mostly going
sideways right
we hit the low here at 9 13 9 14 9 15 9
16 9 19. all right then we rally we
rally about 10 points what is there in
the order flow that's telling you you
know hey you know what maybe this
selling pressure
has subsided
okay now that doesn't mean that you're
going to get a rally like we like we're
experiencing right now
um where we're you know we're up about
30 points 35 points but at least to
catch a bounce in the market right quick
five ten points
because what happens is after a Time
certain amount of time after you make
that low and you do rally then you start
to see more order flow come in it could
either be bullish or bearish you still
have to take into account the order flow
that's coming in okay is that like oh my
gosh you know I got some bullish order
flow down here this is it this is going
to be the low for the day because what
can happen well bearish order flow could
come in as we saw up here right when we
after we bounced up about 10 points
more bearish order Flow came in but more
importantly what's the market telling
you down here at this low between nine
12 and you know basically 9 20. well all
right we're coming in we're coming in
pretty hot here right some strong
selling you know
um you know cash had been open for about
45 minutes you could see you know nice
strong Delta minus 1600.
we're still above the low then we're
coming down into the low we're coming in
strong right minus 1200 into a new low
when I talk about minus 1200 I'm talking
about the Delta Delta's minus 12.
uh 22 1222 new low Delta is just minus
254.
positive Delta 453 it's the Divergence
negative Delta of 390 positive Delta of
286.
small Delta minus 9 small Delta minus 42
positive Delta of 362. okay
that's a lot of numbers there what does
it mean well
coming into a low strong selling that's
what you expect to see
but then we're at the low
and what are we seeing are we still
seeing strong selling well
no negative 254 minus 390 you do have
some aggressive buying coming in
plus 453 on the Delta plus 286 okay
over here you get the two red candles
okay red candles maybe they're selling
but if you're looking at the Delta it's
pretty evenly distributed the aggressive
buying and the aggressive selling right
the Delta is minus nine minus 42.
then you get here you got
negative I say positive Delta of 362.
but what else is what else are you
seeing in here
okay I mean you have to look a little
bit deeper
when you first hit this low
what's the cumulative Delta minus 4242.
you're still at the low here
six minutes later
what's the delta
it's minus 3500
okay now granted you know this bar here
and strong negative Delta of 1200 but
even if you take that out before this
you know here it's you know minus 39 88
minus 254 minus 3700 minus 41 100 minus
3 800 minus 39 minus 39 minus 35
82. so
we're at our low
there's trading going on there's buying
and they're selling aggressive buying
aggressive selling
this Market's not going lower
right because we just keep hitting this
low at 12 at 13 and a quarter
the aggressive selling
isn't strong anymore cumulative Delta
has actually gone up
right I mean people say you know as you
know has it really gone up well it's
minus here's minus 39.88 here's minus 4
200. over here is minus 3 500.
right so if you're looking for this
Market to keep selling off you'd expect
to see you know stronger selling
pressure not the buying pressure coming
in 453 286 362 then you know a small bar
here 61 and then 600 right and then we
just you know pop up from 18 all the way
up to 25. and then the bearish order
flow starts coming in here obviously you
see all that negative Delta and we come
down into new lows
okay and we get down to again these new
lows down here
right right in this bar at 958 right the
low is four and three quarters and we
rally up to about 15.
what else do you see in here again you
know this is what I talk about looking
at the order flow right any not trying
to predict a low but rather seeing how
this low has developed
and is currently trading right that's
the benefit of the order flow
is seeing what is taking place
and making a decision based off of it
okay come in again nice strong selling
into the low minus 555. you know it's
closing on its
Min Delta number Min Delta is minus 556
close that minus 555 that's why it's
magenta then 798 again still strong
into the new lows here okay then one
this bar here it's not on the low so one
tick above the low
but now we're seeing some nice
aggressive buying taking place
right it's 451 is the Delta it's closing
near its Max Delta of 452. okay and then
a bar you know it's kind of yeah kind of
a nothing bar in the sense of in terms
of Delta it's just 20. then this bar
here
340 is the Delta which is its Max Delta
actually this bar
we had a strong negative Delta minus 480
and it closed at 340 on its Max Delta so
there was that selling early in this bar
because you know minus 480 is kind of a
decent strong negative Delta that's
forming in this bar early because it's
happening probably within the first half
of the bar I'd imagine
so it looks like well hey you know what
maybe we could test this low and go
lower but lo and behold
once that selling got shut off
the aggressive buying came in you see a
stacked buying and balance in this bar
you see the green the blue value area
which tells you it's a very bullish
value area
and again
look at the cumulative Delta from the
time you hit the low minus 6000
to this bar
minus
5800 so it's about 800 contracts
to the positive side is gaining it back
so you know once you start adding in
some of them then you see you got an
exhaustion print here you got some
stopping volume
you could feel pretty confident that hey
you know what maybe this Market can
bounce at least I'm not saying it can
reverse and start trading you know back
up to unchanged or to you know the high
of the day but at least a bounce right
I mean when you're at the low first
thing you're going to look for is a
bounce right I mean you want to look for
a reversal but take advantage of the
bounce first right and then if it's
building on each other if it's if that
bounce is building on itself then yes
it's going to be a reversal but
reversals start as bounces first before
they become reversals and let's just
sort of fast forward
um you know let me just find one of
these areas where you know the market
didn't really bounce right and just sort
of went down to new lows okay so for
example here right we're coming in nice
strong selling right minus 1400 Delta
minus 700 minus 700 Delta
to a new low
you get a small positive Delta 209 732.
hey this is it maybe we can bounce again
another 10 points to chain right but
what happens
well kiss the dot that inside bar right
this red bar then you get the negative
Delta
241 negative Delta 600
all right so if you're looking for this
bounce you know it's probably not going
to happen I don't like the
get some sign that hey you know what
maybe we got a bounce taking place and
then it sells off and then all of a
sudden out of nowhere the balance comes
back I mean it can happen and you know
everything happens in the markets but
that's not really what I'd be looking
for and again right you get some buy you
know 32 positive Delta 446 nice positive
Delta okay can we build off of it no it
doesn't go anywhere
okay so again you know
watching the cumulative Delta right
because you're going to say well this is
minus 8
241 in the cumulative Delta here at the
low we're over here at 75.23
why you know maybe I should look for
this Market to go up
okay if what are some of the signs the
other signs that you're looking for this
Market to go up we're looking for a
price Loops are trading higher
it's not really trading higher right and
the majority of the positive Delta on
this move from minus 8241 to minus 75 23
or even here minus 76.
it's just coming in on two bars
of which we don't even trade any higher
on
right so even though it's gained back
some of its negative cumulative Delta
it's basically coming in on one or two
bars and what that could be to me is
more of a sign of you know maybe it's
just some profit taking because again
you know we're making new lows shorts
you know they want to book some profits
okay but the fact that we can't even go
higher than this bar here at 98 and a
quarter again is not a good sign
and you still got some strong selling
coming in here in this bar minus 600
okay now again this one if you're
looking to buy out a breakout you know
maybe from a move from you know 99 right
here to maybe you know 05 or 60708
the fact that this next bar goes inside
is like the kiss of death I
hate getting into a trade and seeing the
next bar go inside of the bar that I
liked a lot which was this one
okay then you know we came down here
made this new low right low low low
testing and testing it
and then pops up again for you know from
this area in here you know 95 it's all
the way up to 0304
you know here now you're seeing
something slightly different okay
cumulative Delta coming into these lows
okay we'll
actually got stronger but
there's a reason for that because you
know you come in here you know came with
some adults is minus seven six nine nine
even here at the low it's minus seven
six five eight way over here it's minus
eight thousand so it's actually gotten
stronger people might may start to think
that okay let's have Delta is getting
stronger
this Market should sell off I mean it
eventually did but you gotta bounce here
because why well even though you've got
negative deltas
right this is negative now this is a
doji candle okay so it's open and close
at the same price that's why it's all
grayed out well
you got some decent volume coming in
here
okay you've got the three 396 313 the
506 okay
over here right that's why you got this
negative Delta of minus 500 right
because there was some volume in here
again it's one of those things right we
don't draw a ratio on a doji candle
because
we want to draw them on um green candles
underneath
for bullish ratios or bearish ratios at
the top of red candles
so just by looking at this I could see
this 506 I can see this negative Delta
which is really what's causing that
Delta the difference in the cumulative
Delta here right from 7600 to minus 8
000 that's that is 500 more or less but
down here I can still see that volume
the 541 now I've got a bullish Prominent
Point of control I've got this negative
Delta on this green candle which is
telling me that there's some absorption
coming on that there's some strong
passive buyers in the market absorbing
whatever aggressive selling so if now
again this one is slightly different
than the previous ones I just talked
about if I know
I have absorption taking place at the
low I definitely want to be positioned
to take advantage of any bounce
this is your bullish Prominent Point of
control that's this magenta line here
right and we have a nice move up back up
to you know the double O area and
eventually a little bit higher before we
sold off down into new lows right now we
got this big massive move taking place
off of this low and
you know again just really quick you can
just sort of see the Deltas taking place
here right look at this coming into the
slow coming in hot new lows of the day
79 here and a half right strong selling
minus 1432 Delta minus 698 Delta and you
go inside minus 10.
positive 571.
positive 1100.
strong selling that's getting weaker
then nice aggressive buying coming in
nice bullish permanent point of control
came back tested it and then again you
see
some decent aggressive buying coming in
here
and it was Off to the Races now there's
things in this up here but I'll talk
about this in in another video or
tonight in my weekly training session
because there is some very nice
information taking place in here all
right everyone so I'll end that video
for today and again you know if you find
these videos helpful
be sure to subscribe to the channel so
whenever I put up a new video you'll get
notified and again remember right order
flow
doesn't always give you every single
turning point in the market it's not
designed to but what it does though it
tells you these things you know these
situations that arise that are so
Crystal Clear sometimes to Traders
when you know what to look for that you
can take advantage of them
all right so have a great uh rest of
your day I'll catch you guys on the next
video bye bye